among the 50-plus uh attendees that  salon spoke with at cpac in dallas more  than 40 percent said they believed in  august trump would be reinstated somehow  what do they do when it doesn't happen  some law enforcement agencies are paying  attention zachary patrizo writes in  salon that quote on july 13  bloomberg news reported that lindell's  theories are enough to put fbi director  christopher wray and other top national  security officials on alert  for the risk that the former president's  most ardent supporters might again  resort to violence now we're already  seeing dates move around what was once  august 13th now some people say will be  august 21st why well august 21st trump  will be speaking at a rally in coleman  alabama one rumor of new i guess you  could call it a new delusion is that  trump will be reinstated at that rally  by who how it's not exactly clear  because it will never happen